we built a one by one scale replica of
the solar system and whichever one of
these three teams
walks all the way across the solar
system first i will give each of you a
mac
a playstation 5 an iphone and a thousand
dollar beast burger gift card
we need that we need that ready guys
server drop the gates go go
go go go go go go follow me and the
challenge
has begun guys we're going too far to
the right you guys are splitting up
right now
each team captain has a circle around
them and if their teammates go outside
of the circle
they get poisoned and their health goes
down their way for your team
come on blue's behind us i can't stop
carl how are things going they're going
great they're going great holy cow we're
actually making kind of progress
we can still win we're not out yet get
to the portal guys we're at the portal
we finished the sun
they're all going through to get to the
next planet you have to enter the portal
at the end of the planet
that's how you jump around the solar
system mercury
everyone hit at the portal hit at the
portal kill white team white at the
first portal chris and chandler's team
had a strategy
camp and kill carl's team he's almost
dead
i got one no i'm dead you died it's just
two of us
oh my god yo they're right behind us
and when people die in this race they
don't come back they go to prison
shoot up chris you're leaving your
people behind the more you fight the
more you lose
gail jailer blue's hitting we gotta go
we gotta go we gotta go
chris what's your strategy right now
we're trying to kill chandler early
if you die you're dead if you die that's
it wait you guys didn't know that
maybe you should get a better team
captain blue's honest blues honest holy
oh run i'm dying i'm gonna die i'm gonna
die
i think orange is actually thinning out
like a lot we're playing aggressive this
game
we see nothing but blood in the water
wait carl where'd your team go
they all died better off with just one
person because then we could run faster
we are only on planet number two in the
universe and chandler and carl both only
have one player left on their team
this will be interesting carl you're
about to make it through mercury do you
know what comes after mercury
venus why does it look so cutesy oh carl
you left your teammate behind come on
man
hurry there's a creeper chris and
chandler's strategy against carl
might have backfired look at how far
ahead he is oh blue's behind us
oh we gotta go we're now on venus and
carl's in first place
chandler's in second place and chris is
right behind in third
there's giant e girl shooting lava at us
i didn't know venus had this
oh my god oh oh
i got sniped by a blaze i see team white
we gotta pass them hurry hurry they're
behind us i see him now i see him now
carl's teammate is lagging
behind and slowly carl down and chandler
took the opportunity to run ahead
we're passing carl oh wait did you just
overtake carl yeah
i only have two people it's just me and
air stalker even though chris isn't dead
last
he still has almost his entire team left
oh no
he's gonna take us out i see white team
yeah cscs gang up on him go go
go go go oh be careful there's lava
right here you might not believe your
eyes but chandler's in first
dude these blades have aimbot oh
i almost fell in lava oh i see the
portal hey chandler chandler i put you
in a call with carl i think you two
should form a truce
why a truce you guys in total have four
people
chris's team has five if you don't work
together chris will destroy you guys
he's right are we choosing yeah let's
truce truce we're on earth baby
this way all right go for the portal go
for the port of white on the other side
we gotta go we gotta book it we gotta
book it it's an amazing race where is
the portal
chris's team is camping the portal carl
can't make it we need to run in the
right direction somebody appointment
uh this way if chris catches up to us we
die
get in my vote get in my vote i'm trying
i can't get in now all the teams are
currently on earth
in real life and in the game we didn't
tell the boys this but the builders hid
some very helpful items inside of
earth's landmarks what is that
do you see that it's a distraction yeah
we gotta stay in first so we're done
is this it wait
beacons are loot beacons are loot i
think they're docking right there we're
gonna go around this island yeah they're
talking right there this is where we
take
the lead and jaina bread we need to make
ground now we're in russia i'm pretty
sure the portal is in china
oh yeah i think it's up here i see it
all right we're on mars
we're on mars holy crap i can jump
there's ice
we should try an ice boat you're right
let's go let's go
carl you're big braining it i am yes sir
oh shoot we're on mars now chandler's in
first place
carl's in second and chris is still in
third is that white team that's white
team
wait why team where oh carl's gaining on
us all right we
got to speed up mars is cool maybe we
should go to mars
i never noticed that planet in the sky
that looks really cool
and speaking of things that look cool if
you go through this portal
you're teleported to the uno mobile
arena cause they're the sponsor of the
video
and server passed the challenge and tp
all the boys to the arena
i'm challenging all of you guys to round
up uno mobile in this coliseum
whoever wins this game of uno your
sister gets 10 grand
carl you're going down draw a card oh no
uno mobile is a free app that you can
play anywhere even on mars if you wanted
they have internet on mars
and on top of that uno is celebrating
its 50th anniversary with a championship
tournament running from the beginning of
july to the end of august i'm also going
to be participating in this uno
tournament because i want to figure out
who the number one player is
hey draw six chris there are many game
modes you can play like high stakes
all in or invite your friends and play
2v2 the app is literally free and
there's tons of prizes you could win and
if you use my link down below this video
you also get 200 coins for free when
installing what the heck are you waiting
for
download it now uno
should i reverse it reverse no oh i win
easy i'm the best una player in the
universe congratulations chandler are
winning 10 grand for your sister
server teleport us back to the challenge
and i'm not done playing nudo yet no
carl blue team's right on your heels man
oh my god and i just got my freaking
wither skeleton you fight i'm gonna keep
going you're sacrificing
you we're winning it you understand kill
him kill him kill him kill him we can
kill him on mars
no oh my god get him get him get him get
him get him get him die with honor freak
oh no nice go go go go go go go go go go
go
you saved me some time i'm not gonna lie
i got away though carl sacrificed his
only teammate just to get a little bit
ahead of chris
he's all alone now we're at the portal
yo we're murdering them
all right we're exiting mars jupiter
carl welcome
to jupiter i fall so much faster i
forgot that the gravity is different
jupiter all right welcome to jupiter oh
my god there's a cow tornado
oh my gosh let's go go go we'll all
follow the same path
yo we are cooking 400 blocks ahead
there's nothing out here this is
emptiness
i'm all alone by myself you literally
are the loneliest man in the world right
now
we can still do this we've got a couple
more planets to go
right now we need to focus on speed ah
the cows there's a cow nato blocking oh
imagine losing because of a cow nado i
made it i made it
saturn best hula hooper in the galaxy yo
saturn cow i'm just running alone
get away why is there's a bee and two
enderman's on me
i'm just gonna keep going i don't care
i'm just ignoring them chris is also on
saturn still in third place
and is in a desperate need of a way to
catch up we gotta go we gotta make
ground
saturn on the map looks insane oh we got
enderman don't look at the enderman
keep your eyes down oh my goodness we're
actually so far ahead
oh let's go you know what comes after
saturn the uranus
it's a funny planet name i can't wait to
get in your anus
kill it yo this enderman's hot on your
tail
yeah bro we can't kill him we've hit him
like eight times yo he's still chasing
you
here we go i mean you're is oh wait ice
ice
ice boats oh my god
what wait wait wait how do you steer
this thing
i'm not leaving the entrance of uranus
until carl comes through
huzzah welcome to uranus
uranus oh my god guys i know you're not
here to experience it but i made it to
uranus
why is it so [ __ ] ah neptune water's
wet
ah go go go chris and carl almost done
with uranus and chandler's halfway
through neptune
alone i miss my team guys we forgot to
make a bunch of uranus jokes sorry we're
focusing on trying to win playstation 5.
sorry uranus i'm going and you might be
thinking chandler easily has it in the
bag there's only one planet left but
pluto isn't any ordinary planet it's a
giant
nearly impossible to climb mountain okay
they're catching up a little bit that's
fine
i'm like 400 blocks behind chandler
before you enter this last portal i want
to let you know the people
you killed from chris's team early on
they are now turrets
on this planet and they will be shooting
you with arrows oh i see him are you
gonna let your teammates down
i gotta get you the stuff i'm getting
shot go go go
who just put loud what it's switching
between lava
i'm gonna die what the heck are these
barriers where do i go
it's beautiful the portal i'm on pluto
oh wait i can go through here it doesn't
turn into lava chandler carl's catching
up to you oh he's right behind you
ah run hey there's two of you and only
one of them
no oh oh
maybe there's a small sliver of hope go
go go go
i killed one girl got me no
frick oh chris is coming up wait are you
guys gonna team up on chris
see you guys later you nerds wait how
did you make it pass
oh my god i have one heart oh oh jailer
who's shooting me
oh my god oh dear heavens parkour
oh no is there any way to get around it
oh i've blocked that blocks that blocks
that vlogs
wait oh i did it i did it
what happened teammates congratulations
spacex each one of you are gonna be
getting a brand new iphone
back playstation five and a thousand
dollar beast burger gift card
we did it
we'll work on that we'll work on that